Oh, femme unique,
Péché, désir
Pour un serpent de Bible,
A brisé son empire
Bleu de l'enfer,
Couleur amour
Dessine sur la pierre
Les mots du premier jour
Saveur amère
D'hommes interdits
A goûté les plaisirs
Que Dieu punit
Coeur mortel
Eve aux yeux pâles
Délaissée par le ciel
Elle a mal
Eve lève-toi et danse avec la vie
L'écho de ta voix est venu jusqu'à moi
Eve lève-toi tes enfants ont grandi
En donnant la vie je serais comme toi
Eve en musique
Fille en délire
Pour un enfant d'Afrique
A perdu le sourire
Eve en velour
Chagrin d'amour
Chemin du petit jour
N'aime plus rien
Femme future
Sur ses trésors
Le corps en aventure
Elle s'endort
Eve lève-toi et danse avec la vie
L'écho de ta voix est venu jusqu'à moi
Eve lève-toi tes enfants ont grandi
En donnant la vie je serais comme toi
Ne pleure pas
Ton histoire est là
Regarde-moi
Ta vie est en moi
Le temps s'efface
Eve lève-toi et danse avec la nuit
L'écho de ta voix est venu jusqu'à moi
Eve lève-toi tes enfants ont grandi
En donnant la vie je serais comme toi
Eve lève-toi et danse avec la vie
L'écho de ta voix est venu jusqu'à moi